Fuck tipping culture and fuck Dutch brothers.
Because I've heard many people say that you don't tip
and then they make your coffee wrong.
And what happened to me this morning,
I didn't tip and didn't make my fucking coffee wrong.
And I wouldn't be super, like,
paranoid about it
if it weren't for the way the girl at the window looked at me.
She was like, you got the two,
blah, blah, blah,
said it right, and then handed them to me.
Another thing that they always do,
they always put the little sticker to cover the whole.
They didn't. Like,
she didn't do none of the shit that they do.
And again, I've heard it online from other people that Dutch brothers,
specifically, when you don't tip at the thing,
they're gonna fuck up your order.
Good job, Dutch Bros.
You lost a customer today.